hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the joy of creation
this time it's the Halloween edition and
this time it features I'm assuming
that's gonna be ignited spring-trap just
in time for the spookiest of Halloween's
so let's get into the adventure of the
joy of creation once more
hi why hello there I see her in quite
trouble who is this who I am is not the
problem now the problem is that you're
currently in a cat-and-mouse game all
right what do you listen closely the
complex you're currently in is like an
anchor to the dead while it still
remains standing
it keeps enraged spirits inside it you
have to destroy the complex and how
would I do that find and destroy the
weakened pipes around the place try
using a blunt weapon such as a hammer to
break the pipes open the flammable gas
will be released then get back to the
entrance of the building and light it up
with a lighter a bow before I forget to
mention it you're not alone in there
and he doesn't like visitors
yeah who he is is not the issue what he
will do to you if he catches you if you
just happen to run into it don't run or
shine your light at him hide as fast as
you can and either wait for him to pass
by or distract him by playing a sound
through a camera speaker with your phone
wouldn't I kill myself by blowing this
place up no who is he and how do you
know all this oh let's just say I have
some history with the place what is that
damn okay so spring-trap stalking
through here this is the place for five
nights at Freddy's 3 you're not gonna
make so I saw him on the camera I don't
know where that is I don't know where I
am
I don't know where any of this is in
relation to anything that I'm doing here
so I am lost like a little baby in the
woods hello is that one of the weekend
pipes that I need to bash with a hammer
I gotta find a hammer oh [ __ ] this is
gonna be a bad
ahh that's familiar hello is anybody
home am I alone here Oh
hammer say yay ok I got a require a
light or two why didn't I get a this
[ __ ] on the way in why am I here
who said you sent me here okay so I got
a don't shine light hide and then
haven't haven't haven't habit having
have wobbu ski have a ski hmm breathing
in that good old natural gas huh all
right sorry lost my composure there that
was not that bad okay so I'm willing to
bet that the hammer is not in the same
place that it was before and I'm just
gonna be stuck wandering like an idiot
early dammit I didn't even see him
coming so I didn't know that he was
gonna be running down the hallway I mean
I did hear him and stupidly I didn't try
to do anything to prevent my own death
it's my own fault I suppose it's not
there it's not even replaced by the
lighter or something okay so let me see
if I can find him the cameras whoo I
found him on the camera don't know where
that is
Hey oh that's weird that's super weird
that's super weird it made him change
directions Oh which is kind of an
important detail to remember here but I
don't know where that is in relation to
anything where are you
right so I got to be on the lookout for
a hammer
[Music]
camping sound still playing a sample
this alright so right says playing sound
I'm not done
that's this case [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you alright
okay that didn't work out so well but
maybe this time it's gonna be better
maybe this time I've got hope I don't
think I do but maybe this time I do
so the Hammers back in this spot again
so I got the hammer okay so now I just
got to break the pipes you're someone
laughing in the distance over there I
don't like that very much
okay so the long haul is definitely bad
that means goddamn I fancy mr. Italy hmm
how am I still alive I've no goddamn
idea
ah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you ah this is the
wrong way hi
well I'm boned my facial okay so I'm
gonna do a very stupid experiment I'm
gonna do what he said and I'm just gonna
understand here if he comes by and I'm
not dead then I know I know how to do
something so that's good I guess
I suppose oh [ __ ] he's coming oh he's oh
hey you coming around that corner
alright oh hey hi I didn't - was a look
at him
oh man that's that's no good that's no
bueno
that's no bueno at all that experiment
failed horribly whoa whoa whoa speedy
whoa slow your roll there buddy boo
speedy bunny in a hurry whoo I didn't
even see that I got the lighter okay
that's good I didn't even know what the
lighter was but I picked it up because I
randomly pressed a button okay that's
good
I like random chance random chances my
favorite thing in games oh oh oh I'm
back in the main office oh hey oh hey
okay so this is exactly a replica of the
main area where's he
the office outside that's where I was
hallway Bonnie Cade room something or
other Oh see him anywhere Grisi foxy run
through a hammer in here oh [ __ ]
come on what am I supposed to do
did I accidentally play a sound in the
exact room that I was was that arcade -
or was that did I do bad there I think I
might have done bad oh whoa
Bailey I run faster backwards holy [ __ ]
well I'm dead Scott Scott ah bundang go
find out about the lightning very very
frightening me holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
I'm dead I did hey there's a sound going
on in the arcade room you want to go for
that I didn't actually play a sound you
stupid it I god I'm dead
ah [ __ ] I know hey [ __ ] you hey hey -
I got two
so I got to just get is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
kinda no don't don't don't do nothing
please please leave me leave me be oh
geez oh geez oh geez oh geez
I think I got away which is amazing by
itself I don't know how the [ __ ] I got
away I don't know I have no idea
oh okay he's over there all right that's
good
so he's far away from me he's pretty
much on the opposite end of the doodad
so if there's one right here Punk okay
then I believe placed one around here oh
geez oh god no
oh my god oh my god I don't know how I
survived that oh I don't know why I'm
trying to you know stay quiet about this
but uh I'm the skirt and death real
clothes here oh my god Oh oh jeez oh
jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh
jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh jeez oh
jeez oh jeez yes yes yes yes yeah light
it up light it up Mitch laid it up what
the [ __ ] what
why are you kidding me what the [ __ ]
happened did I not do it what the [ __ ]
was that
was there no into it what the [ __ ] I
just did it I just did it okay I'm
pretty sure I did it like I'm pretty
sure I did it I got the requirements I
got the hammer I got the lighter I'm
pretty sure that's just scripted to be
like you can never escape argh
oh my god you and then you know that's
done so I'm pretty sure I did it so that
was the joy of creation Halloween
edition I like it it's good more concise
in the story more explanation in what
you're supposed to do and more purpose
in the objectives which i think is a
very good thing so let me know what you
think down the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching the final
demo will be available like tomorrow or
something so you'll be able to play for
yourself very soon so thanks again and
as always
in the next video
[Music]